hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to a fight to the death
go go go Marcus team up with me I came
up with a wait a minute what is
happening Oh marks almost dead give her
heart
why hey wait how do you have full health
what is I don't know oh no I spawn back
at the place Oh zombie come I'm not
there sorry okay
Oh giggles all right let's see the proof
of my skill I didn't know we don't even
know that you won so I'm gonna assume
yeah bah blah yeah I won I'm pretty sure
Bob in there what I I saw it yeah I so
what - yeah okay everyone saw Bob won
Bob wins is all right as a reward for
Bob winning Bob gets to go first in our
little game of Pictionary picks name
names are work in progress but basically
what's gonna happen is oh but that prove
we got a little dispenser here that's
gonna spit out ideas for fun perceived
derp I love it I love is ami and of Bob
gets to go first and he's gonna build it
and then we're gonna try to guess what
it is
alrighty as we're going along and we got
it I don't know do we have to type it in
we don't have the time we can teach
other I hate you guys so much what you
get would you get that is not how this
game works
would you kid needs some of you oh you
were oh yeah we died we didn't have her
inventory shoulder we originally had our
inventories are the only two colors that
I need because this person is a
douchebag oh do I have like a time limit
or anything or ah it's just I guess is
it I guess we don't really know the
rules to this so
all right go do a waiver fails all right
start up the edge so I can take full
advantage here okay and what am i
standing on I don't know the the Great
Wall of China
oh you're standing on that is the
dispenser for the ideas oh it's just
Gorky / oh you know we building a
scorekeeper let's go
oh it's gonna be lazy um diarrhea
um Rick yes no a house it's not even
close yet hang on Jalen capitis you may
like two seconds here okay it'll start
to make sense are you sure about that
oh yeah a smack pyramid not a pyramid -
so why can't I build here
well a bottle of beer I like this is a
very crucial part of what I'm building
and I can't build on the edge there yes
very good it should arbitrarily to find
the thing of course it's not like it's
said in the game this now yeah rules are
rules you cannot build outside of that
quartz yeah it's a dungeon a temple oh
wait way it's time to make sense to me -
hahaha
sir case your idea Yami all right no
it's not my idea I don't even the job
job is it a job job sir poo it's um ah
what is this
I'll give you can I give hints I guess I
donno know you care not boob it's boob
listen it's tip to my nipple the states
Goku's left nipple no anchors right
nipple okay right there boy here we go
ready this is gonna give it away right
here cleavage um sister pay off uh
lopsided boobs yes that was it no way oh
my god yeah that's pretty good was that
those mine no idea oh my god alright so
since I won that round I get to go next
that way I can't win more than one at
once it's a little cheap to give people
their own ideas I guess but ya know it
oh that's another windows like they'll
to Matt's right oh it wasn't my idea but
it still I guess it before you okay well
I guess that's a simple enough so it was
being very creative with their idea here
kill it mark I am doing it okay you
ready
nothing emptiness your youthful penis no
no no no no just give me a second
it's a jackal jackal but I stop the
devil shut up shut up hey shut up again
shut up Marcus or me so many taking a
poop shut up shut up a naked person shut
up shut up shut up just let me work
somebody's hey dude oh stop dancing
around where I'm trying to build please
it's Jekyll Jekyll it's not a jackal
it's not a jackal oh gosh [ __ ] I didn't
not do this right you guys are gonna be
very confused and coloring it to the
details understand as a person like a
skit laptop on their lab amazing [ __ ]
shut up let me work no it's not
Patrick's let me work oh this is Patrick
spongebob penis um a sitting penis
attack pose anyone instructing tiger and
he's not supposed to make sense until
this part comes in so just hang on
is it bad if I think I know what you're
making is I submitted it maybe I don't
know
markiplier sitting in a chair with an
erection yeah we didn't we should have
just had zombie makeup all the ideas as
well yeah should I know that it's chair
dammit you someone Rizal this friend
yeah let's all get rude
maybe the we submit it should not answer
yeah I was kind of thinking we would
just go on the honor system and you
wouldn't guess if it was obviously a spy
should if we should guess no obviously
not who said yes no one said yes yeah I
heard as a soul I just wanna point out
everyone was guessing on the last one
yeah but how me fairly for God
I'm the new drummer Arclight you forgot
that oh wait were you self it was rare
it was a chair was a chair why was there
always much sitting out there no no it's
not you it's her ass wait you bugged up
buyin oh we broke the button your bro
yeah I'm take your break here like I I
get out of the way all right all right
Yami's turn it's a third no you are
never mind you know what I won the
stupid game yeah whatever just
apparently we're gonna forget every rule
we ever made yeah go go we army bit away
this guy's awesome ed this one's this is
your episodes of debauchery okay maybe
we should just build one of the ones
that we picked
yeah whatever we do it I I submit this
one second boys because I'm really do
she won so yeah Bob why did no one
senator why did no one think that there
was gonna be a problem with the person
native made it should I mark a penis
chair legs chair chair only fat kid with
balls all right you me by the way I care
peace um just gonna it's gonna it's uh
long gangrene legs it's um uh Bobby I'm
gonna be pink another way Bobby uh the
UM down let's go it's gout is a guy uh
golden penis is serious Oh pap being PDR
is a beam all right he is it is it
November as an old stripper listing 280z
gold member that would be amazing the
Green goes can you drop me off here
you throw um Bobby Pigman penis hammer
is it a hammer
alright oh [ __ ] once any any black what
oh oh the hammer of Thor Milner Oh penis
hammer this is black okay here uh is it
is it up is it a Brodie pony
sad all right I'm gonna stop take a
second clue soon
why are you done what is this [ __ ] why
give me a second
understanding the yellow brick roads
going to the Emerald City yellow brick
road up an ass yellow click road
reproducing yeah yeah my toes yellow
brick road the vision that zebra chewing
gum the little chocolates the pink thing
is um a part of our body and something
is entering it golden vibration Saxon is
here but sex mm-hmm put your butt or
something that's just something is being
shoved in this ass right is it hanging
up a bite it's a it's a healthy um uh
fruit um banana up your butt yeah but
not in the book is it Richie Furst I
said it I think I said it first
who submitted that yummy did how's my I
did see what the scorekeeper think yeah
zombie member anaronnie who said who
said banana of the but first who said
that no all right yes all right
harness hey since you came last she'll
turn right way go wait no way just build
one of yours that you suggested just
make it easier but this thing does he
built for us
[ __ ] that sick bet in the bunt cleared
just enjoying it
oh we replace the suggestions all right
okay
ooh I like it really this is what I get
to crap oh wait actually a bunch of crap
is it it's a bunch of crap I also do it
gotta go fly in kombu Polly diarrhea two
girls one cup three girls one cup three
girls one cup rock girls three cups okay
crying is this someone crying weeping
crying man is he crying big baby big
bubble blowing baby you're on the right
idea am i huh weeping angel uh
why sobbing weeping profusely what is
this thing I think we know what this is
supposed to be eyes
supposed to be a face yes what are you
doing you guys are dumb
Wade crying yes how do we know that was
you think have you seen my minecraft
skin it's right in front of you do not
give a [ __ ] am i right around good
that's a minecraft face well I guess I
won but I don't want me to win that
minecraft face that is going to be all
right you know what I'm gonna deduct
points for myself I've down back to one
oh that seems arbitrary mark you
shouldn't be so good at this game and
you all go here there we're all tied yes
all tied for no monitor really tense why
did I have to pick myself crying oh god
damn it Bob I am getting another button
hang on oh how could you keep breaking
the button oh there is another button Oh
told me to break the last burn haha oh
my god okay it was a good office teracle
it's pretty funny okay come on come on
bring it on I gotta get some walls out
you didn't have wool already ready I had
my own I always playing with C and T and
stuff is it a naked mole-rat playing the
piano yes that's it that's you win Oh
Joely good job Wade that was impressive
I get another gold block over here no
you have a gold block on your head don't
worry about it do what bill the gold L
baton I think there goes a jar using the
texture pack to ice dirt face
you broke Lib quartz to God I am i
drunker than I do feel like I am what's
going on bakers have you been doing
Romeo I don't want to do that no no I
don't have all the rightful either who
says slipperiness dreams with eyes
oh is it feet Slenderman Slenderman
okay okay okay okay okay oh this isn't
Shenzhen okay well it's three days 3d
okay all right hmm pancake drugs on it I
think these are legs I know it Bob the
Builder they are little higher
this is Makapuu as a right track but
it's a very specific way I wouldn't wait
sad annual wait so how did you say wait
um naked marks stomach
Malcolm ayah naked me naked me oh yeah I
gotcha same you need okay maka partial
us no maka it's not pink its skin is
skin color oh okay the pink is
participants oh okay
fairness month markiplier yeah markable
are wearing the mustache took over pig
applier mustache like took over
completely no no no no no this playa
maka penis uh turn well surprisingly
yeah it's not terribly far away oh oh my
Johnson Marga dick dick 'mark dick
applier obvious like Marcus not would
not be okay with well uh Maura used only
to a penis mark genetically modified
himself to only be a penis uh markup
without his head will face that's what
it's a really specific word that yes cut
the word you're looking for is an
adjective and it's used to describe a
specific type of people in not a
terribly positive way I guess aah-ha-ha
do supplier Yahtzee
ah damn it
wait I dick is good dude alright this
dick closed no damn it
what that was it hey get your own so if
this markiplier was a real person he
would come in and he'd be like hey guys
Morgan where's here
hey markiplier no different not
different he's not just gay could be
straight but he's very a feminine
applier girl liar vodka play girl hey
girl
he hasn't take though normal more okay
so yeah uh okay
Diaby that's a really good idea except I
have to get whole bunch of colors of
wool for that uh liar
I'm so lost track I want everyone in the
comments guests along with of like what
the hell is this yeah austere go putting
some guesses what you doing now well
what is that is that like my arm and I
turned into Slendy plier Oh
oh gosh it better not be are you just
that what is this blandly world are you
doing rock apply a naked on the moon
bang boom barker rainbow ah it's a
rainbow flag yes cuz i'll gay cuz i'm
gauged cuz i'm gay right it's it's it's
it's it's a different it starts with an
F the word starts with an F oh no I
thought it was gonna be bad for a
security plier I caught close close
close close oh um four flaming plier oh
so close
come on is it literally a variation of
the word flaming flame apply er no damn
it burn a fire on fire apply it all the
way wrong way wrong way uh it's a word
that's commonly used to describe people
mark and it's more flaming I mean do you
guys want to keep guessing or yeah is it
do you have any money yes uh it's a god
I mean I don't know how else to portray
the word and I'm supposed to be
portraying here a flash the pot lame it
was close to flame has the some
variation of markiplier but fire the
blame of well if you were describing a
guy who like smell like sweet cherries
and walked around I was always really
loud he would say that he's really
flamboyant
the pliers my boy markiplier yes yeah I
should not he should not get the puck
for that yes
nobody's that flamboyant since I right
no what if we did hey I'm out of the
hair voice before me day everyone
showing up yamimash apparently zombie
thinks the yamimash got that yeah mommy
why didn't you stop us nothing's Ami's
in control of this trainwreck oh it was
funny was it oh that's a uncouth all
right here I go
what am I good Oh what how in the world
okay alright then um oh god how do I do
this
which one of us does this in love how do
I do this how do I do
I really don't know okay alright need
huh mom Bob you dirty cheat it was like
this when I found it right okay
marks I wouldn't know like I like the
way this is starting yeah thank you but
my make it Slenderman
no like odd I wonder what naked
Slenderman would look like I hope
someone draws that next on uneven legs
okay just give me a second for Easter
guessing spongebob that's a real person
but in the same shape of spongebob oh
god how do I do this crouching fisherman
eating hodges's stairs
skyline's legged weirdo how do I do this
cow what are you drawing screen here I
shut it for a second I got this in
lessons shutter speed warp snow version
conscious oh my god I wish you can see
this from a distance mark I can't shut
up
it's it's Qbert is it Qbert no it's not
Qbert is this like a love hand it what
did you say wait handle I forgive you
for everything that wasn't me
I miss my Prairie no it's yamimash is
turned another way to tell me Rice's
turn I can't either
oh I got it I was gonna fill it in white
pink fact I don't know how to do it true
yeah you pretty tough to drones okay so
uh both young mashing wait or one point
from winning I've been forgiven for
everything guys not all right god I
really hope I really hope the audience
is playing along in the comments below
because alright what do we have here Oh
nazi Slenderman sheep a sheep
Santa sheep for hugs Powerpuff Girls
bubbles oh did you think of the game
again baby baby baby are you singing
Christmas carols cuz that's a clue
oh no it's never you Christmas I'm just
in the festive spirit okay what it's a
British Christmas coming up real soon
um uh uh metrical cow and sir
later hosing I put that the is it even a
person I don't think it's a person and
mybay sheep man man sheep away hmm
Bob one set oh my god is it pop the pop
wait I need to readjust lamb wait my
skirt
okay Dexter
stirs laboratory what is it can it does
look like that kind of does yamimash are
we getting closer we way off base yeah
you again very close okay so something
with Bob ah
Bob with a goiter uh uh let's see what
exploiters I just hear people say it
Bob flipping everyone off calling
everyone a dick
this one mm-hm what was in it
no okay there it was Lee Bob with a
weird broken neck thing and something's
wrong with my head is it Bob mixed with
something else bomb thing with the llama
on a hot night that's it is it me as a
wolf
no Baba sheep no Bob giving its double
middle finger
uh Bob with the double flipping us off
that looks a member I'm not bending over
for something
headless Bob flipping us off Bob with
shoulder muscles name with huge muscles
Oh Bob see oh what's that
what it's around that variation of Bosco
muscle on modular mice consoles uh fide
Bob Popeye Bob is duck stirred the so
bub if you just saw it is you want it to
start you know weightlifter Bob Bob
what did you say wait body building Bob
yes that's it Oh Lister oh god damn it
Bobby gets to make the call but I said
weightlifting Bob I think that was
pretty close yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
right yeah suck it Wade yeah suck that
Wade is right nope too late too late
after I got it partially right enough
all right wait your turn
go go go it was a skill er go go blow d
yo yeah you all should drew oh crap am I
gonna make this go away go hurry up
working on at that time we gotta go
someone's got her your winner huh oh man
come on baby go go
uh-hmm
is it 2d or 3d what are you doing here
up I don't know some hurt I'm doing uh
knuckles uh how's it guess with knuckles
yeah thank you
that's why that is dribbles right stuck
this bullet uh uh uh Powerpuff Girl um
boy de is it a goiter we don't know what
boy days but I'm I guess he'll every
time will give me the definition of
Nagoya in the comments
I gotta would please explain what that
is in the comment I guess I could look
but that would require changing screen
yeah um uh uh wait wait is he you know
okay
is this it is that the whole thing are
you done hahahaha how about you get off
your ass and start giving us more we're
editing colors right it's it the French
flag oh is it an animal this gas has
been me but it's not me Robbie big
flappy bird it's a wage mom's it ah wait
oh well I'm getting plowed Wade's mom is
it ways mom wait a second it's me isn't
it wait yes
oh go I mean I say am i late yamimash
lying-down UMMS after he got kicked in
the balls yamimash runnings no it's not
mocking much okay hmm
yamir ass running from all the families
that's really fast yummy Fox roll the
Droid off-screen Amy - yeah yummy yeah
super yummy mash yamimash holding a
giant pokéball huh it's not a book of
all uh me uh got me a bunch of run over
by a bus car yamimash in front of a
youtube or next to a YouTube will get
run over your clothes Marc yamimash
getting hit by bus yamimash getting uh
getting on a salmon run over by a Red
Guards taking it right over what would
it be flat you ain't happy man it's
yummy much dick off your mashed potatoes
you guys hit Mike on dead
yeah we must they're hit by cars what is
it John Tesh every corpse traffic out
the omission of traffic at Johnny's
statistic
yummy you call animals in her hit Jojo
okay oh yes dice a first I think I said
that first oh that was close I think you
run ahead
okay yeah I got the point according to
zombie that dang it okay
that's the worst car I've ever made my
finger on match point hey yeah I should
build the next one I think zombies
should build it cuz we're all tied up I
think Johnny she build this god dammit
why do I have to die Nate try to build
as fast as possible it was really crappy
turning house not as fast as possible
Oh zombie has a oh my god he's here oh
my god the same girl never did well
alright so zombies gonna do this the
tiebreaker round this is intense
I know right oh gosh I should probably
move to a spot where I can see what he's
actually doing baby this is something
every Slenderman slide these nipples
slant against lenders balls so the sling
his tits it was actually in shape oh
that's low that's low oh shut up I'm
trying to get in shape maybe you know
Enderman um a really tall guy a guy with
big head bit trip honey uh uh if it had
legs a creeper a black Krishna ubirr
Jennifer Lopez hybrid a creeper being
said a cream wanna do kiss is now uh
eating a chair shooting a creeper eating
celery people be sick a creeper puking
puking up for puking slender object
vomit hold it oh yeah oh baby I want to
be worries me I won twice baby if you
counted oh hey we need to quit this
serious place of the word Marc doesn't
win I won twice is this just my cousin
me drinking he's been cheating I've been
drinking I need another beer though I
really do
oh yeah yeah yeah I do the other beer
okay alrighty then
alright that was fun
hope you all were play in the comments
below so thank you all so much for being
here thank you Bob you're welcome thank
you Yami Nash
oh you're welcome [ __ ] love money
list go [ __ ] yourself
oh ha Thank You indeed oh my gosh how
about fire forgive it once a part time
alright and thank you everybody so much
for watching as always we'll see you in
the next video what you doing there Bob
see you guys but I shot